[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
euren um ihren live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussionen
ein ja ist das terror attentat vom
hanauer jetzt her und seitdem steht der
name der stadt in einer reihe wie
rostock lichtenhagen mühlen oder auch
münchen das sind alles orte in denen in
den vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten
rechts terroristen menschen aus
rassistischen motiven ermordet haben
die angehörigen der opfer von hanau
stehen auch ein jahr nach der tat
natürlich immer noch unter schock jeden
monat am 19 treffen sie sich um
gemeinsam zu trauern und ihrer
hintergründe ihrer opfer zu gedenken
heute ein jahr nach der tat findet eine
große trauerfeier statt mit sehr viel
prominenz die wollen wir die nächsten
zwei stunden jetzt mit euch verfolgen
von 18 bis 19 uhr wird diese trauerfeier
gehen und danach möchten wir reden über
die vielen offenen fragen die diese tat
immer noch nach sich zieht über die
ereignisse die nach wie vor ungeklärt
sind das ganze werden wir besprechen mit
meiner kollegin susanne santina die seit
einem jahr recherchiert zu dieser nacht
und den darauf folgenden fragen und
merkwürdigkeiten die sich dort ergeben
haben und mit armin foto vich das ist
der vater von hansa coach der an diesem
abend von dem attentäter in der arena
war ermordet wurde
wie immer könnt ihr uns die fragen
stellen und kommentieren bitte aber
heute besonders mit dem gebührenden
respekt der dieser abend verlangt
derzeit ist dafür da dass wir gemeinsam
gedenken dass wir uns auch über die
fragen gedanken machen auch die gerne
diskutieren können die wir eben immer
noch haben aber dass dann eben ein ort
des gedenkens sein das jegliche art von
propaganda oder hass oder hetze werden
wir hier nicht dulden und sollte das
ganze nicht gelingen werden wir den chat
auch dann leider zu machen müssen aber
ich hoffe es wird nicht so weit kommen
fragen und kommentaren natürlich auch
gerne per mail an zdf heute - live at
zdf.de das werde ich dann auch hier auf
den rechner kriegen und dann werden wir
schauen was wir davon in der sendung
verarbeiten können aber erstmal schalten
wir jetzt zu meinem kollegen peter
wagner der ist
in hanau vor ort und beobachtet die
ereignisse peter was passiert gerade
ja gerade in diesem moment ich weiß
nicht ob man es unter mir noch sehen
kann ist bundespräsident war der frank
walter steinmeier eingetroffen er geht
jetzt in den saal wer ist also der
letzte der ehrengäste der heute abend
hier ist und von ihm wird auch eine
große und sicher auch wichtige
gedenkrede erwartet mit wichtigen
botschaften
das ist das was jetzt gerade passiert in
etwa 5 minuten soll dann die
gedenkveranstaltungen losgehen und es
ist dort ein programm vorgesehen
eröffnet wird das ganze durch den
ehrenbürger von hanau den ehemaligen
fußballer rudi völler
er wird da ein zitat von wilhelm grimm
verlesen und die ähren kerze entzünden
eine gedenk kerze dann gibt es einen
film rückblick und dann werden
der hanauer oberbürgermeister kaminsky
und der hessische ministerpräsident
bouffier die opfer namen verlesen ein
sehr wichtiger moment die namen der
opfer zu nennen und die namen auch nicht
zu vergessen und dann kommt die
gedenkrede des bundespräsidenten und im
anschluss daran wird armin kovac sie
hatten ja gerade erwähnt für die opfer
die hinterbliebenen und deren familien
sprechen und soweit ich gehört habe hat
er auch heute eine wichtige botschaft
sich vorgenommen
in hama jetzt ein jahr danach gesprochen
ich habe leider die frage nicht gut
verstanden ich habe sehr starke
störungen auf den ton noch mal bitte ich
stelle sie gern noch mal ein jahr nach
der tat wie wird in hama über diese
nacht gesprochen
wer vor allem mit fassungslosigkeit
entsetzen mit trauer aber auch mit
respekt dafür wie die familien die
hinterbliebenen die opfer mit dieser
schrecklichen tat umgehen wie sie es
bewältigen wie sie jeden monat wieder an
diese terror nacht gedenken und wie sie
das andenken der opfer lebendig halten
ein jahr ist das attentat jetzt her in
der nacht von freitag auf donnerstag auf
freitag damals kamen die meldungen erst
gegen mitternacht was wirklich passiert
ist in dieser nacht das wurde erst in
den darauffolgenden tagen klar wir haben
eine kleine chronologie der ereignisse
zusammengestellt
hanau 19
februar 2020 gegen 22 uhr nähert sich
tobias er zwei lokalen am heumarkt im
zentrum von hanau in der bar la botte
erschießt einen mitarbeiter ko an welt
oft auf der straße vor der bar fathi
sarah schule in der shisha lounge mit
neid deren eigentümer sedat kürbis
tobias r wird draußen auf der straße von
willi viorel paaren beobachtet
dieser sitz in seinem auto tobias r
schießt auf ihn aber willi verfolgt den
täter trotzdem zu seinem zweiten tatort
dort wird er später tot in seinem auto
aufgefunden
tobias erfährt nach hanau kesselstadt
dort schießt an einem kiosk und einer
benachbarten bar wieder um sich tötet
fünf menschen
gürkan gültekin mercedes kierpiec
hansa-coach zeitmesser haschemi und
ferhat unwahr und verletzt weitere der
täter fährt weiter zu seiner wohnung
ganz in der nähe
dort erschießt er mutmaßlich seine
mutter dann sich selbst
insgesamt sterben bei dem rassistischen
anschlag elf menschen
entweder wir schalten jetzt sofort live
zu ihnen hinter hinter ihr sehen das
kongresszentrum denn ich sehe dort rudi
völler der jetzt mit der trauerfeier
beginnt der alle anderen gefühle bald
überflügeln
mehr als alles andere das ruhige und
gedeihliche leben eines staates das auf
der inneren gesinnung der menschen
beruht nicht auf bajonetten
es dauerte fünf minuten und 6 sekunden
[Musik]
fünf minuten und 6 sekunden in denen
neuen menschen starben fünf minuten und
6 sekunden nach den für neun familien
nichts mehr ist wie zuvor
die sinnlosigkeit des geschehens die
bisherige realität aus ihren angeln
zurückbleiben trauer und
fassungslosigkeit
am abend des 19 februar 2020 sterben bei
einem rechtsextremen anschlag in hanau
neun jungen menschen gekannt gültekin
sie dort gewiss
[Musik]
seit der sarrazin
mercedes kam sarkowicz billy powell
fathi surur
serhat unwahr kalorien mehr kurz
es ist 21 58 am abend des 19
februar als ein rechtsextremer und
psychisch kranker mann am hanauer
heumarkt mitten in der innenstadt zu
schießen beginnt in zwei lokalen und auf
der straße tötet er kaltblütig drei
menschen die nicht so aussahen wie er
sich deutsche vorstellt dann steigt der
tat in sein auto der 22 jährige billy
viorel paaren beobachtet das geschehen
und verfolgt den schützen mit seinem
eigenen wagen vom heumarkt bis nach
kesselstadt dann den
kurt-schumacher-platz während der fahrt
versucht willi mehrfach über den notruf
hilfe zu bekommen
als der täter seinen verfolger bemerkt
erschießt der willi in seinem auto in
der arena war und im kiosk daneben reist
der attentäter weitere sechs menschen
brutal aus dem leben
die opfer waren zwischen 21 und 37 jahre
alt sechs weitere menschen überleben
teils schwer verletzt hanno steht unter
schock
deutschland steht unter schock
rechts der oben menschen sterben gegen
22 uhr täter die ganze welt nimmt anteil
nach der schrecklichen tat und der
hessische ministerpräsident volker
bouffier sowie viele weitere hochrangige
politische vertreter und unterstützer
nach hanau
die bundesanwaltschaft übernimmt die
ermittlungen der hanauer
oberbürgermeister claus kaminsky stellt
von anfang an die unterstützung der
familien in den mittelpunkt aller
bemühungen letzten stunden zeit ist ein
abend 22 uhr gehören zu den traurigsten
stunden die diese stadt in
friedenszeiten niemals erlebt war in den
folgenden monaten finden in hanau immer
wieder demonstrationen und mahnwachen
stadt hanau steht zusammen gegen hass
und rechts terror die familien der opfer
wollen verhindern dass so etwas noch
einmal geschehen kann
ein jahr ist vergangen zwölf monate in
denen die neuen familien der
verstorbenen versuchen ihre trauer zu
bewältigen den alltag trotz allem zu
meistern
aber wie knüpft man an ein leben an das
nicht mehr ist wie es mal war
das schafft man nur mit hilfe und
unterstützung durch gespülten
zusammenhalt und durch die gewissheit
dass nach antworten gesucht wird eine
tat wie der anschlag in hanau fordert
unserer gesellschaft heraus
wir müssen selbst im spiegel betrachten
rassismus ist ein problem in deutschland
rechter terror versucht unser leben zu
erschüttern unseren friedlichen alltag
anzugreifen
kano stellt sich dem ganz klar entgegen
arno ist offen für vielfalt das leben
ist bunt tolerant
dieses lebensgefühl muss mehr denn je
für alle geschützt werden denn wir sind
es ihnen schuldig party-village de
[Musik]
wer hat mercedes
becker
sie dachte
[Musik]
hansa
und seit netzer
der abend des 19 februar die unfassbare
tatsache dass ihr nicht mehr da seid
paterno das herz gebrochen
ihr werdet geliebt und unendlich
vermisst
ein jahr ist nicht eure familien sind
sehr tapfer und kämpfen für euch hallo
kämpft für euch jeder soll eure namen
kennen
ihr werdet nie vergessen
[Musik]
wir gedenken heute der opfer des
rassistischen anschlags vom 19 februar
2020 gökhan gültekin service
seit dem ii mercedes skripotschka
genannter big willi wiemold partie
saracoglu ferhat unwahr kalorien welt
kopf wir werden sie nie vergessen
[Musik]
verehrte trauergäste den 19
februar 2020 hat sich tief eingegraben
in unser gedächtnis ein jahr nach den
brutalen morden in hanau sind wir heute
wieder hier beisammen und der
furchtbaren ereignisse zu gedenken
aber vor allem und der opfer zu gedenken
um ihre namen zu nennen ihre namen zu
erinnern und nie zu vergessen sich noch
einmal dem schmerz und der trauer zu
stellen das ist für uns alle an diesem
tag ein schwerer gang aber das gilt
zuallererst für sie die verletzten die
angehörigen der opfer ihre engen freunde
sie die jetzt hier sind oder wegen
corona dieses stunde des gedenkens am
bildschirm mit uns da sie alle haben
menschen verloren menschen die zu ihnen
gehörten deren gesichter und deren art
ihnen vertraut er die teil ihres lebens
war
all diese geliebten menschen sie waren
einzigartig und einmalig und deshalb
auch wenn die opfer und auch wenn sie
die angehörigen hier von einem grausamen
geschehen gemeinsam betroffen sind
deshalb ist doch die trauer und der
verlust
die ein jeder und eine jede verspürt
einmalig und ganz besonders deswegen
gedenken wir hier jedes einzelnen namens
und jeder einzelnen mit diesen namen
verbundenen lebensgeschichten
und deswegen kann hier jeder seine ganz
persönlichen trauer noch einmal raum
geben jenem ganz persönlichen abschied
schmerzt den jeder und jede allein für
sich zu tragen hat dessen last niemand
wirklich abnehmen kann
so sehr wir uns auch gegenseitig stützen
und trösten vermögens natürlich können
wir nicht übersehen was die toten um die
wir trauern verbindet sie sind alle
opfer eines täters geworden der in
mörderische verblendung in ihnen eine
ganz bestimmte gemeinsamkeit sehen
wollte allen opfern war in seinen augen
gemeinsam dass sie nicht hierher gehört
nicht hierher nach hanau wo die
ermordeten lebten wo sie geboren wohin
sie gekommen waren wo sie ihre heimat
hatten und von wo aus sie ihre
lebenspläne machten und diese
verwirklichen wollten der täter machte
sich das recht an zu entscheiden wer
hierher gehört und wer nicht er maße
sich das recht an zwischen wir und die
zu unterscheiden
darüber zu richten wer hier leben dürfe
und wer nicht
er maße sich das recht an über leben und
tod anderer zu entscheiden
jeder einzelne jeder einzelne mensch um
den wir trauern war einerseits ein
zufälliges opfer weil er gerade dort war
wo der täter seinen mörderischen plan
umsetzen wollte andererseits waren die
opfer alles andere als zufällig weil sie
in der hasserfüllten vorstellung des
täters nicht hierher gehörten gerade
deshalb waren sie das präzise ziel
seines tödlichen plan
auch deswegen hat diese tat ein solches
entsetzen ausgelöst nicht nur aber
gerade unter allen menschen mit
einwanderungsgeschichte sie hier wissen
jeder andere von ihnen hätte opfer
dieses mörderischen anschlags werden
können und vermutlich wollte der täter
seine tat genau so verstanden wissen als
fanal als kampfansage an gefundene
formen friedlichen zusammenlebens diese
perfide botschaft verbreitet deswegen
nicht nur entsetzen sondern nach angst
diese angst haben viele und nicht nur
ein handel und ich kann diese angst
verstehen
der täter hat seine ideen ja nicht nur
aus sich heraus geschöpft oder von
allein entwickelt er hat durch sein
umfeld das internet und soziale medien
eine vorstellungswelt kennengelernt in
der seinen rassismus und seine in wir
und die unterteilte weltsicht immer
weiter geprägt und verstärkt worden ist
diese von hass und vernichtungs
fantasien bestimmte weltsicht wird immer
noch tag für tag verbreitet
von menschen fanden die wissen was sie
tun
so wie der mord an regierungspräsident
walter lübcke kein zufall war
und auch nicht das attentat auf die
synagoge in halle
so waren auch die morde in hanau kein
zufall
die taten waren von gesteuertem hass
initiiert und die täter davon ermutigt
[Musik]
hass rassismus hetze gegen muslime und
juden überlegenheit fantasien all das
richtet sich sehr genau
gegen sehr bestimmte menschen menschen
die unter uns leben die zu uns gehören
zu unserer stadt und unserer
nachbarschaft die mit uns dieselben
schulen besuchen in denselben leben
einkaufen derselben arbeit nachgehen so
viel gemeinsame alltag der zeigt dass
wir zusammengehören
trotz unserer unterschiede aber die
wahrheit ist es gibt die die schon auf
verschiedenheit mit feindschaft
antworten die sich in einer welt
einrichten in der nur die eigene
vorstellung ihren platz die sich selbst
erhöhen indem sie anderes abwerten
für die klar ist dass verschiedenheit
bekämpft werden muss
und genau das soll durch ideologie und
lüge durch hetze und ausgrenzung in
unsere köpfe gehämmert werden die
bösartige menschenfeindlichkeit die sich
im netz oder anderswo zeigt ist das
gefährliche gift einer kleinen
minderheit aber ein gift das wirkung hat
ein gift das immer wieder menschen
glauben macht sie dürften im namen eines
angeblichen volkswillens andere menschen
demütigen bedrohen jagen oder gar
ermorden
was kann unsere antwort auf die
schrecklichen taten von hanau sein
was muss unsere antwort viele antworten
viele gute antworten sind gegeben worden
hass und rache waren nicht dabei das
böse wird nicht durch böses besiegt bei
den guten antworten denke ich zb an die
vielen spontanen demonstrationen und
mahnwachen die direkt nach den
furchtbaren meldungen hier aus hanau
überall im land stattgefunden haben
hanau steht zusammen war eine dieser
spontanen aktionen die viele andere nach
sich zu ich weiß unsere mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger diejenigen die bei sinn
und verstand sind die herzen
die wollen ein friedliches zusammenleben
sie wollen nicht unterscheiden zwischen
wir und die sie möchten ein wir und ganz
viele setzen sich überall in unserem
land dafür ein dafür dass hass und
gewalt des missachtung und
respektlosigkeit unter uns keinen platz
finden sie setzen sich dafür ein dass
wir alle ohne angst verschieden sein
können dass wir alle ohne angst
voreinander miteinander leben können
ich denke an vieles was hier in hanau
geschehen ist für sie mit ihnen den
angehörigen der opfer aber auch gerade
an das was von ihnen selbst ausgegangen
ist
ich denke dankbaren die begegnung mit
ihnen schloss bild über der wir
versucht haben die furchtbare tat und
die folgen für jede einzelne familie
noch einmal aufzuarbeiten einen weg der
für sie sicher nicht einfach war
ich denke an die praktischen die
psychologischen auch die materiellen
hilfen die hier von stadt land und bund
gegeben worden sind aber vor allem denke
ich an die zahlreichen beweise von ganz
einfacher mitmenschlichkeit viele ganz
normale menschen ohne amt und auftrag
haben wir etwas getan für das sie gewiss
keinen besonderen gedanke erwartet ich
will aber trotzdem gerade heute allen
danken für ihre zugewandtheit für ihre
hilfe als sie sich gebraucht wussten für
all das was sie für eine gute eine
bessere zukunft hier in hanau getan
haben und weiterhin tun
die stadt hanau und die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieser stadt gesellschaft haben
hier ein engagement gezeigt wie ich es
in dieser form und vielfalt wirklich
selten erlebt habe
dafür möchte ich als bundespräsident
noch einmal ausdrücklich danken der name
hanau steht nicht nur für schlimme
verbrechen
es steht auch für eine lebenswerte
heimat in der man sich kennt sich hilft
und füreinander da ist
zu den wichtigen aber ganz und gar nicht
selbstverständlichen initiativen gehören
vor allem die partnerschaften die
initiative 19 februar hanau die
bildungsinitiative fährt unwahr und so
vieles andere was im kleinen und im
großen geschehenes bis hin zur
errichtung und pflege der gedenkstätte
für die toten
die ehrengräber und das digitale denkmal
am heutigen jahrestag wir wissen
miteinander nichts von dem was geschehen
ist kann wieder gut gemacht werden aber
die vielen kleinen beiträge von denen
ich gesprochen habe können vielleicht zu
etwas führen was für manche heute
vielleicht noch ein zu großes wort sein
mag das aber das ziel alle unserer und
ihrer bemühungen sein könnte rückkehr
von vertrauen endig vertrauen in diese
stadt in dieses land das unsere
gemeinsame heimat ist und bleiben soll
ich weiß dass es trotz allem was an
gutem geschehen ist
auch deutliche kritik und fragen an das
staatliche handeln gegeben hat und
weiterhin gibt ich bin als
bundespräsident nicht hier weil ich
antworten dass alle offenen fragen habe
dann ich bin hier weil mich zutiefst
bedrückt dass unser staat sein
verbrechen sein versprechen von schutz
und sicherheit und freiheit dass er
allen gibt die hier gemeinsam friedlich
leben dass er dieses versprechen
gegenüber ihren angehörigen nicht
einhalten können
ich weiß
das berührt ihr vertrauen in diesen in
unseren in ihren staat
es darf uns nicht gleichgültig sein denn
der staat die demokratie braucht
vertrauen justiz und polizei brauchen
vertrauen was sie polizistinnen und
polizisten gerade in extremen
situationen aushalten müssen und leisten
wird oft weder gesehen noch respektiert
und ich beziehe ausdrücklich auch die
ärztlichen pflegerischen notfall und
rettungsdienste mit ein
aber auch der staat und alle die ihnen
eben verantwortung tragen sind nicht
unfehlbar
nirgendwo auch nicht in deutschland
und wo es fehler oder fehleinschätzungen
gab da muss aufgeklärt werden
aufklärung und aufarbeitung stehen nicht
im freien ermessen
sie sind die bringschuld des staates
gegenüber der öffentlichkeit und vor
allem gegenüber den angehörigen nur in
dem maße in dem diese bringschuld
abgetragen wird und antworten auf offene
fragen gegeben werden kann verlorenes
vertrauen wieder wachsen
deshalb müssen wir uns so sehr darum
bemühen
der staat ist gefordert aber genauso
sind wir es jeder und jede von uns viele
sehr viele zeigen es tag für tag im
selbstverständlichen miteinander des
alltäglichen lebens oder in besonderen
initiativen die unser gemeinwesen
schützen tragen
und wir spüren und erfahren wir sind
dabei nicht allein
wer sich für friedliches zusammenleben
einsetzt ist in bester gesellschaft der
ausgrenzung ablehnt
findet freunde nachbarn mitbürger die
genauso denken und handeln
ich versichere ihnen verehrte angehörige
es ist die überwältigende mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land die gegen
ausgrenzung gegen rassismus für
demokratie ist aber richtig ist auch
diese mehrheit muss sichtbarer werden
liebe hanauerinnen und hanauer liebe
angehörige und freunde ein jahr ist es
her dass die trauer nun gewichen ist der
schmerz geringer die wut verflogen sind
alle fragen beantwortet nein keineswegs
doch als bundespräsident stehe ich hier
und bitte uns ich bitte uns lasst nicht
zu dass die böse tat und spaltet
übersehen bin ich die bösen geister in
unserer mitte nicht den hass die
ausgrenzung die gleichgültigkeit aber
bitte lasst uns glauben an den besseren
geist unseres landes an die kraft zum
miteinander den willen zum gemeinsamen
wir wenn wir diese botschaft
verinnerlichen und hier und heute aus
hanau mitnehmen dann ist die heutige
stunde der erinnerung und der trauer
vielleicht auch eine stunde der hoffnung
und zuversicht für hanna für hessen für
ganz deutschland
[Musik]
unsere uns allen gemeinsame heimat
vielen dank
wir gedenken heute neun junge menschen
denen aus fremdenhass das leben genommen
wurde
durch den brutalen verlust geliebter
menschen sind trauer und schmerz
fassungslosigkeit entsetzen bei den
hinterbliebenen unermesslich für die
familien und freunde der opfer waren die
vergangenen zwölf monate
die schlimmste zeit ihres lebens und
dennoch ist der wille um aufklärung
ungebrochen denn sie sind wir alle sind
es den opfern schuldig wir möchten eine
lückenlose aufklärung
wir möchten auch das schonungslos gegen
die vorgegangen wird die ihren job nicht
gemacht haben jeder der sich nicht an
die regeln gehalten hat seine
amtspflichten verletzt hat sondern dazu
auch zur rechenschaft gezogen werden und
das ist das mindeste was wir machen
können wir wollen lückenlose aufklärung
die behörden sollen ihre fehler zugeben
wenn die zuständigen behörden ihre
arbeit richtig gemacht hätten würden
unsere kinder noch leben
ein land in dem die menschenrechte im
grundgesetz verankert sind muss in der
lage sein menschen vor rassistischen
anschlägen zu schützen
wir eltern haben schlaflose nächte
können die zuständigen in ruhe schlafen
seit den 80er jahren geschehen immer
wieder morde aus rassistischen motiven
immer wieder kam hinterher heraus dass
es hinweise auf die täter und karten da
warum gehen die behörden solchen
hinweisen nicht nach bevor es zu spät
ist
ich fordere die zuständigen politiker
und behörden auf jetzt endlich ihre
pflicht zu tun
gewaltverbrechen aus rassistischen
motiven frühzeitig entdecken
und verhindern die sachen gehört zu
meinen kennt die habe ich alles
aufgehoben für meine enkelkinder denken
sie darüber nach
meine bitte ist oder appelliere an die
politiker an die fall fort wegen meine
tochter wurde anschlag ermordet worden
ist diese terroristische wie dich für
meine frau holle tableau wo ihnen die
strafhaft im rosenheim ist ein offener
vollzug dass ich mit sie zusammen um
meine tochter lauern kann ja meine
wichtigste frage ist wie diese rasse ist
eine waffenschein besitzen durfte und
wer ihn das ausgestellt hat er war ja
seit 2002 regelmäßig im amtsgericht
gewesen seine akte ist voll und wir
haben auch durch ein akt mitbekommen
dass er 2002 auch in einem
psychiatrischen klinik war und dass der
vater ihn auf diese psychiatrischen
klinik mit zwang unbedingt raus geholt
hat aber in seinen gesundheitsakte stand
ja noch extra angekreuzt nicht geheilt
und mich interessiert auch wie so eine
gesetz 2002 verabschiedet wurde
wo gesagt wurde ab 2012 braucht man in
waffen an nicht mehr gesundheitsämter
nachzufragen
also die fragen nur bei lka nach ist er
sauber oder ist ja nicht sauber und er
kriegt ne waffenschein
wieso wird auch nicht bei gesundheitsamt
nachgefragt ob er psychisch in der lage
ist geistig eine waffe zu tragen weil er
hat ja auch verschwörungstheorien gehabt
er hat ja auch schizophrenie gehabt und
deswegen
dürfte er niemals einen waffenschein
bekommen und hätte der beamte seine
arbeit richtig gemacht und in keine
waffenscheine ausgestellt was er hätte
nie passieren dürfen werde meine bude
heute am leben und darum will ich dass
rechenschaft gezogen wird das
konsequenzen gezogen werden dass jeder
der fehler gemacht hat auch zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden muss und
bestraft werden
die verantwortlichen politiker müssen
sich ihrer verantwortung bewusst sein
und müssen rede und antwort stehen für
die fehler die vor der tat während der
tat und auch nach der tat passiert sind
damit so was nie wieder wenn deutschland
passiert warum ist mit so geworden waren
hatte waffen und warum hat alles
geklappt und der citymanager
durchgegriffen
eckart bohn ist rassismus prat wir haben
welche die bürsten durchmesser magazin
der deutschen studenten die sich gerade
dort leichter
warum die deutschland die polizei die
den bundesanwalt hat nichts die familie
informiert wo ist mein sohn diese fotos
städten internet ab 19
er war halb elf ich war selber zum
polizei mit meiner frau die zweite tag
ich hab keine ahnung dass meine sony
gestern die klamotte vom chemie hand
gekommen bei mir nach hause
die nackte komplett sie banal sieben
monate arbeit von polizei
ich bin gestorben in dieser nacht
trotzdem mein sohn hat kehrt seiner
dokumente seiner portemonnaie die auto
hat gab durch die kennzeichen
was steht in die akte ist die dritte
person welt hat telefonie zum notruf in
dieser nacht es gibt gutachten für diese
zentrale keiner sagt nix gesagt schuldig
und ich muss immer daran denken die mine
soll schwer verletzt wurde und niemand
hat rechtzeitig nach ihm gesehen niemand
hat ihm geholfen
bis heute weiß ich nicht wann genau die
letzte minute seines lebens war ich weiß
auch nicht wann jemand mache meinem sohn
geschaut hat und wann jemand seinen tod
festgestellt hat wäre er weniger stark
verletzt gewesen
vielleicht hätte das entscheidend sein
können ich würde alles dafür geben noch
einmal mit ihm zu sprechen ihn zu sehen
ein moment mit ihm zu verbringen wir
vermissen ihn jeden tag ich hätte meine
wut mit hass mischen können
aber das habe ich nicht gemacht ich will
für die anderen kinder und jugendlichen
um den sieg kämpfen für hartz iv darf
nicht mit seinem tod endet
deswegen habe ich bildungsinitiative
ferhat umwelt gegründet
die schule ist ein ort an dem wir mit
dem kampf gegen rassismus beginnen
müssen
die bildungsinitiative soll eine brücke
sein zwischen lehrern und müttern und
kindern und jugendlichen
ich möchte keine vorwürfe machen sondern
fürchten nicht schaffen
deutschland gehört uns allen
unsere kinder sind unsere zukunft
wir müssen unsere kinder mit respekt
behandeln damit aus ihnen gute menschen
melden ohne rassismus und ohne hass auf
andere für ein gutes zusammenleben in
hand und fuß hat
[Musik]
liebe trauernde und an teilnehmende
heute ist es ein jahr her dass mein so
und acht weitere menschen opfer eines
rassistischen terror anschlags wurden
seitdem steht die welt vorstellt nichts
ist mehr so wie es einmal war
tagtäglich sind wir gezwungen zu lernen
mit dem verlust unserer eigenen kinder
zu leben
wir alle möchten heute daran erinnern
dass die namen unserer kinder und ihre
besonderen persönlichkeiten nicht
vergessen werden dürfen
fertig der viel lachte und gerade dabei
war seine eigene firma aufzubauen
wer hat der einem immer zugehört hat und
immer den passenden rad hatte bürgern
der sich zuerst um alle anderen
gekümmert hat bevor an sich selbst
dachte hamza
der sonnenschein der familie kalorien
der nach deutschland kam und die
augenoperation augenoperation seines
sohnes bezahlen zu können
mercedes die eine liebevolle mutter und
die beste freundin ihrer kinder war
zeitmesser der immer ein lächeln im
gesicht hatte und andere zum lachen
brachte statt der die freiheit das
reisen und den sommer liebte und willi
der das einzige kind seiner eltern war
der tragische held dieser nacht sie alle
waren junge menschen die ihre träume
noch nicht gelebt und ihre ziele noch
nicht verwirklicht haben alles das mit
ihnen immer verwehrt bleiben wir danken
ihnen verehrter herr bundespräsident für
die aufrichtige und erkennbare
mitfühlende begleitung in den letzten
schwierigen jahr
wir schätzen es sehr dass sie als
höchster repräsentant unseres landes von
anfang an bis jetzt glaubwürdig die
haltung deutschlands zu diesem
schrecklichen anschlag vertreten
im besonderen maße möchten wir uns bei
ihnen herr kaminski dafür bedanken dass
sie so viel bewegt haben wir wissen dass
sie alles in ihrer macht stehende getan
haben um an die opfer zu erinnern bis
heute setzen sie sich für die lückenlose
aufklärung der geschehnisse in der
tatnacht ein
wir schätzen den regelmäßigen austausch
mit ihnen und ihre unterstützung sehr
weiteren beistand erhielten wir von
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
bundesjustizminister pro land bricht den
bundes opfer beauftragt
dr franke und im landes opferbeauftragte
per 5 sind und einige abgeordnete des
bundes sowie landtags bei denen wir uns
ebenfalls bedanken
kraft trost und zuversicht gibt uns auch
die breite anteilnahme und die sehr
konkret der unterstützung durch die
initiative neunzehnter februar nicht
zuletzt möchten wir uns bei der
zivilgesellschaft für ihren
unermüdlichen kampf gegen hass gewalt
und rassismus bedanken ebenso bedanken
wir uns bei den journalisten und medien
die uns die ganze zeit über begleitet
haben und dazu beigetragen haben dass
dieser schreckliche tat um unsere kinder
nicht in vergessenheit geraten
es wäre aber keine ehrliche rede wenn
ich nicht über die offentlichen
missstände und im mangelnden
aufklärungswillen sprechen würde
tagtäglich fragen wir uns wie es so weit
kommen konnte ob die tat nicht hätte
verhindert werden können
es ist so schwer zu begreifen dass so
etwas in unserer stadt geschehen konnte
noch immer haben wir viele fragen die
nicht beantwortet wurden wieso wurde uns
verwehrt
uns würde voll von unseren kindern zu
verabschieden seit einem jahr versuchen
wir selbst antworten auf unsere fragen
zu finden
da wir bei den zuständigen stellen kein
gehör finden und immer wieder abgewiesen
werden es ist sehr bitter und es tut weh
dass die behörden in hessen erst durch
strafanzeigen offene tragen gezwungen
werden mussten sich den wohlbekannten
versäumnis auseinanderzusetzen
die antworten fielen immer noch
es ist enttäuschend und es ist
unerklärlich dass alle hinweise alle
eindringlichen bitten und gespräche
vielfach abgeblockt wurden
es reicht nicht aus zu sagen hanau darf
sich nicht wiederholen wir dort so
ziemlich jeden einzelnen bürger dieses
landes müssen alles tun um die
fragwürdigen umstände aus der tatnacht
des 19 februar 2020 restlos aufzuklären
wir wissen dass wir die tat nicht
ungeschehen machen können und uns nicht
unsere kinder zurückbringen wird jedoch
darf sich so eine tat nicht wiederholen
kein mensch sollte auf seine art und
weise aus dem leben gerissen werden um
rassismus nachhaltig aus unserer
gesellschaft verbauen zu können müssen
wir auch verstehen welche großen
einfluss die sprache hat insbesondere in
der berichterstattung wenn in
zusammenhang mit einer
rechtsextremistischen tat von fremden
oder fremdenhass gesprochen wird erzeugt
das automatisch ein gefühl von wir und
die anderen diese spaltung dürfen wir
nicht weiter zulassen
unsere kinder waren keine fremden
sie waren liebevolle und hilfsbereite
kinder geschwister eltern und freunde
sie waren bürgerinnen und bürger dieses
landes die aus dem nichts aus der mitte
unseres lebens gerissen wurden mit der
hilfe sie uns alles dafür zu tun dass
dieses leid keine familie mehr
widerfahren wird stellvertretend für
alle neuen familien stehe ich heute hier
weil wir es unseren kindern schuldig
sind wir dürfen und werden nicht
zulassen dass unsere kinder umsonst
gestorben sind ich danke ihnen
[Musik]
herrchen das um 19.02 beginnen wird
so wird also die trauerfeier aus hanau
aus dem kongresszentrum bei mir im
studio ist susanne santina kollegin hier
von mir im zdf die seit einem jahr zu
den vorfällen recherchiert hat und auch
eine dokumentation erstellt hat die seit
heute online ist in der wirst du sehr
viele fragen auf über einige wollen wir
jetzt hier reden aber erstmal die frage
an dich wie hast du das letzte jahr
jetzt eigentlich erlebt innen und mit
hanno weiß ich war ja recht früh danach
in kontakt mit den angehörigen und habe
dann die komplette trauer erlebt die
verzweiflung dieses ungläubige dass sie
einfach nicht verstehen konnten warum
ihre kinder ihre brüder und schwestern
sterben muss nur weil sie keine
deutschen wurzeln hatten ich glaube das
war das was einfach gar nicht bei den
leuten ankommen will konnten das nicht
verstehen
mit der zeit habe ich gemerkt die trauer
jahr die traurigkeit blieb aber auch
immer mehr die wut das heißt sie waren
unzufrieden weil sie gesagt haben wir
werden über die ermittlungen gar nicht
informiert
und je mehr sie selbst ermittelt haben
desto mehr haben sie festgestellt und
jeder läuft einiges schief da gibt es ja
verschiedene punkte die hab ich auch in
meiner dokumentation erzählt stichwort
notausgang kann man gleich nochmal
drüber sprechen vater des täters und wo
sie gesagt haben wir sind wir die
eigentlich immer daran sind dran zu
bleiben zu recherchieren und dann
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft
und ihr ermittelt nicht von amts wegen
das hat mir zum beispiel auch annika
topitsch gesagt er jetzt hier auch
gesprochen hätte gesagt es kann doch
nicht wahr sein dass wir als angehörige
immer dafür sorgen müssen dass die
ermittlungen in gang kommen konntest du
dein so recherchiert hier vorgestellt
hast oder wie war der umgang mit den
behörden mit den verantwortlichen die
sich ja auch tatsächlich einige fragen
gefallen lassen müssen also für diese
dokumentation aktuell habe ich wirklich
kein einziges interview vor der kamera
bekommen leder von der polizei
südosthessen
die sind ja zuständig für herrn noch vom
hessischen innenministerium noch vom
bundesinnenministerium weil alle drei
wären da gefragt gewesen
aber die fragen schriftlich beantwortet
haben sie mir ich hatte im mai 2020
hatte ich mit der polizei südosthessen
tatsächlich noch reden können und da
habe ich sie noch gefragt zu den
notrufen von willi fahren weil der vater
hatte mir kurz vorher das handy gezeigt
und gesagt wenn es mein sohn hat
versucht die mehrmals die polizei zu
erreichen hat es mir auch gezeigt und
ich wollte dann von der polizei wissen
warum hat die polizei eigentlich diese
anrufe nicht angenommen genau das können
wir uns mal anschauen einen ausschnitt
aus seiner dokumentation genau zu dieser
frage was ist eigentlich mit dem notruf
passiert in einem video einer
überwachungskamera vom tattag ist oben
rechts willys auto zu sehen
tobias er rennt an ihm vorbei willi
fährt mit seinem auto zurück nimmt die
verfolgung auf bis zum zweiten tatort im
hanauer stadtteil kesselstadt dort wird
willi später von der polizei tot in
seinem auto gefunden
seine eltern erfuhren am nächsten mittag
dass ihr sohn ermordet worden war
warum ist das passiert was passiert
drei monate nach der tat trafen wir
julia und niculescu baron zum ersten mal
niculescu zeigt uns das handy von willi
dass sie am vortag von der polizei
zurück bekommen hatten
willi hatte in der tatnacht mehrfach
versucht die polizei zu erreichen
hinter verfolgt hat viel markt der von
ihr zum polizei war und keine antwort
von polizei und das verstehen dass dies
keine hatte den beiden damals gesagt
dass willi versucht hatte die polizei zu
erreichen und den täter zu stoppen
sie selbst haben es recherchiert und die
tat nachts rekonstruiert tja also ein
polizeihund ruft er nicht erreichbar ist
susanne wie kann das sein wird die
polizei das erklärt also die polizei ist
da glaube ich nicht der richtige
ansprechpartner es war dann der
hessische innenminister und der hat dann
zugegeben aber erst vor kurzem dass das
notrufsystem in halo veraltet war das
heißt es gab keine weiterleitung
automatisch bei einer überlastung an
eine zentrale leitstelle die müssten
eigentlich geben
die gibt es auch in anderen hessischen
polizei dienststellen in hanau nicht und
außerdem kam noch hinzu dass an diesem
in dieser tat nacht nur ein beamter vor
ort war
das heißt unterbesetzung das ist
eigentlich auch nicht so vorgesehen
nein natürlich nicht also bei notrufen
müssen auf jeden fall da reicht ein
beamter nicht das wurde ja auch als
fehler eingestanden aber auch jetzt erst
auch da ich hab's ja auch gesagt die
familie hat selbst recherchiert hat die
tat nach rekonstruiert die haben sich
das video angeguckt die
überwachungskamera haben gesehen
mein sohn ist vorne bertling täter
hinterher das haben sie alles selbst
gemacht
die polizei hat sich nicht informiert
und erst dann haben sie sich an uns
gewandt in dem fall auch an mich ich
habe ja die familie ganz früh getroffen
nachdem also ich glaube das war ja genau
ich hab es auch gesagt am tag nachdem er
sein handy zurück bekommen hatte der
vater und die mutter und das ist
wirklich so sie finden was raus sie
erzählen es uns medien und irgendwann
mal kommen dann die ermittlungen in gang
hier gibt es auch schon die frage auf
youtube ob es konsequenzen in solchen
fällen gibt auch für die polizisten die
mit den verletzten vor ort
nicht um professionell umgegangen sind
oder nicht umgegangen sein sollen gab es
da irgendwelche konsequenzen auch für
sowas wie den notruf der nicht besetzt
war bislang nicht weil die ermittlungen
noch laufen das muss man ja auch sagen
also das ist ja so dass die angehörigen
schon dafür sorgen dass die ermittlungen
in gang kommt aber die sind noch nicht
beendet
ein teil des notrufs hat zumindest der
innenminister eingestand doch es gab
eine verwaltung des systems und eine
unterbesetzung aber grundsätzlich auf
polizisten vielleicht fehler gemacht
haben da gibt es ja auch verschiedene
vorwürfe werden zu zögerlich reagiert
werden zu spät rein gegangen
sie hätten sich rassistisch geäußert
haben wir von einigen gehört das kann
die polizei also hat uns die polizei auf
keinen fall bestätigt ich habe sie
danach gefragt aber ich denke das werden
jetzt auch die weiteren ermittlungen
zeigen
es gibt ja noch sehr viel mehr
merkwürdigkeiten zum beispiel auch die
frage warum der täter überhaupt eine
waffe hatte oder waffen hatte die ihr
ganz legal besessen hat obwohl er
bereits in der vergangenheit auffällig
geworden ist und auch da gucken wir uns
mal ein ausschnitt aus einer
dokumentation an philipp gohmann der
vater von mercedes kippt stellt sich
auch viele fragen vor allem versteht er
nicht warum der täter tobias er
unbehelligt blieb obwohl er seine
radikalen rassistischen botschaften
sogar noch kurz vor der tat im internet
geäußert hatte mit die ausländer dass
der elan wurde dem waffenschein verliert
rassistisch gewaltbereit und trotzdem
legaler waffenbesitzer eine gefährliche
kombination tobias er hatte seine morde
geplant mögliche tatorte in hanau
mehrfach ausspioniert wettbüros bars
cafés er wollte da zuschlagen wo viele
menschen zusammenkommen die für den
rassisten tobias er keine deutschen
waren
der 43 jährige war 2002 in der
psychiatrie und später mitglied in zwei
schützenvereinen in münchen und bergen
enkheim 2013 stellte tobias er bei der
waffenbehörde seinen ersten antrag für
eine waffenbesitzkarte
eine rückfrage beim gesundheitsamt
psychische erkrankungen vorliegen fand
nicht statt
und muss auch bis heute nicht erfolgen
das hessische innenministerium sieht
keine fehler
eine rechtsgrundlage für eine
regelanfrage der waffenbehörden bei den
gesundheitsämtern kann nur durch den
bundesgesetzgeber im waffengesetz
verankert werden und vom
bundesinnenministerium heißt es dazu
zur verbesserung des
informationsaustauschs der
waffenbehörden mit den gesundheitsämtern
hat das bmi für die 213 konferenz der
innenminister handlungsempfehlungen
unterbreitet einen konkreten zeitplan
gibt es derzeit noch nicht
fest steht es gibt bis heute keine
regelung für eine verpflichtende
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung durch die
waffenbehörden ein psychiatrisches oder
psychologisches gutachten verlangt das
gesetz nur von bewerbern bis 25 jahre
eine wohl kaum nachvollziehbare
altersgrenze tobias r war 43 jahre alt
ja also auch das noch ungeklärt zu sagen
du hast dich damit ja auch intensiv
beschäftigt ein jahr danach gibt es
immer noch keine neue regelungen wenn
wir uns andere attentaten angucken zum
beispiel aus islamistischen kreisen gibt
es ja sofort immer mit diskussion was
kann man machen wie kann man das
verhindern dann werden mehr befugnisse
für ermittler gefordert wie erklärst du
dir das dass das so lange dauert bis
sieben mal darüber nachgedacht wird was
zu ändern an diesen waffengesetz das ist
wirklich schwierig zu beantworten
tatsache ist dass wir natürlich
nachgefragt haben wir haben ja gerade
dort gesehen innenministerium sagt auch
wir haben es auf der tagesordnung aber
wir haben es noch nicht entschieden
mich wundert warum sie keine
dringlichkeit sehen es ist auch ein
absoluter missstand wenn jemand
psychisch auffällig ist und danach eine
waffenbesitzkarte beantragt dass keiner
der von der waffenbehörde mitbekommt
dass der ein psychisches problem hat
also muss man muss glaube ich sagen
psychisches problem heißt nicht gleich
dass menschen gefährlich sind aber in
dem falle nicht unbedingt aber man muss
wissen wenn man muss es wissen
in dem in der kombination rassistisch
gewaltbereit und auch noch psychisch
auffällig finde ich das sehr gefährlich
und es kann nicht sein dass die
waffenbehörden nicht erfahren wenn
jemand einfach psychisch krank war oder
irgendwie auch auf vorher auffällig denn
er war und das ist auch eine frage des
verfassungsschutzes er war ja vorher
auch auffällig im internet er hat ja
seine rassistischen und wirklich auch
sehr vernichtungs gedanken im internet
geäußert auf seiner webseite hat diverse
anzeigen geschickt an die
bundesanwaltschaft an die hanauer
staatsanwaltschaft und das ist nie
besonders aufgefallen da hat keiner mal
geguckt okay was ist das für ein mann
der jetzt auch noch mit
waffenbesitzkarte möchte da gibt's
keinen kann der automatische abfrage der
keine verbindung das finde ich es
richtig ein problem das heißt es gibt im
grunde kein monitoring für solche sachen
einzeltäter die eben nicht in so gruppen
organisiert sind sondern sich einzeln
vielleicht
seine oder versteckt radikalisieren dann
aber trotzdem auffällig werden durch
solche aussagen ich meine er hat das ja
nicht verborgen getan sondern eben dann
auch durch anzeigen wie du sagst da gibt
es bis jetzt auch kein system um solche
menschen besser irgendwie auf den schirm
zu kriegen das problem ist wirklich
tatsächlich dass man den tätern im
internet scheinbar nicht so gut auf die
spur kommt das war ja bei tobias er
tatsächlich so der war super auffällig
im internet hatte sich aber sonst sagen
wir mal nicht so besonders auffällig
verhalten
und da sind sie den täter nicht auf der
spur das glaube ich richtig ein
riesenproblem weil man sich im internet
natürlich radikalisiert und im internet
die leute die sie auch im internet
radikal sind sind ja meistens auch
gewalt bereit oder können auch
gewaltbereit sein dass man kann dass ich
so allgemein sagen
und da glaube ich gibt tatsächlich einen
defizit so wir warten weiter jetzt nach
der trauerfeier darauf dass
arminen-coach zu uns kommt in den stream
und mit uns spricht nach der trauerfeier
wir haben natürlich auch noch fragen an
ihn wollen ihn zu hören das kann noch
ein bisschen dauern natürlich weil der
kultur wird jetzt erstmal aus dem
kongresszentrum raus muss vielleicht
auch noch ein paar worte wechseln möchte
mit dem bundespräsidenten zum gespräche
ich hier weiter meiner kollegin susanne
santina die sich mit diesem fall ganz
intensiv beschäftigt hat wie gesagt eine
dokumentation erstellt hat die jetzt
auch online verfügbar ist
nach der tat haben sich auch viele
gefragt mussten so viele menschen
sterben neun menschen hat der täter
erschießen können teilweise auch weil es
ihm sehr leicht gemacht wurde zum
beispiel in diesem fall hier
peter erinnert sich an kim die kurz
rausgegangen war und ein alarm schlug
ihm kam er rein und hat gerufen da ist
immer mit einer waffe da kommt jetzt
rein und darauf sind wir halten nicht
zum notausgang gegangen weil wir eben
mussten dass der notausgang zu ist und
wie dort einfach ohne barriere vor den
tätern seine schusslinie gewesen werden
also haben wir uns entschieden nach
hinten zum tresen und zu gehen hat aber
auch noch eine tür und die tiere aber
auch abgeschlossen
und da machen wir in der sackgasse in
der sackgasse weil die notausgangstür
auf der rückseite der bar versperrt war
deswegen ermittelt jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft hanau zeugen sagen
der notausgang sei schon seit langem
verschlossen gewesen weil das ein deal
des barbesitzers mit der polizei gewesen
sei um razzien zu erleichtern
stimmt das ein interview sagt uns die
polizei auch dazu ab schriftlich
bestreitet sie den vorwurf durch die
polizei er geht niemals eine weisung
oder aufforderung notausgänge zu
verschließen oder auf andere weise zu
versperren
im gegenteil werden bei erkennen
derartiger verstöße umgehend die
zuständigen fachdienststellen von uns
informiert umgehend informiert das
stimmt nicht
nach zdf-informationen war schon im
tatort bericht vom februar 2020
bezüglich des notausgangs in der arena
war von verschlossenen türen die rede
konsequenzen gab es keine und die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt auch
nur weil angehörige der opfer anzeige
erstattet haben
ich muss mal kurz auf ein paar
kommentare eingehen so seiner die hier
immer wieder darauf eingehen dass es für
die opfer zum beispiel des anschlags am
breitscheidplatz keine trauerfall
gegeben hätte weiter der bundespräsident
das ist leider eine totale
fehlinformation es gab auch damals an
der trauerfeier es gab sofort natürlich
auch besuche dort am tatort in berlin
durch bundeskanzlerin merkel und durch
den bundespräsidenten von daher finde
ich auch diese gegenseitige aufregung
von opfern und von attentaten also
wirklich nicht adäquat und ich habe hier
einen kommentar der darauf reagiert von
andreas schwartz auf facebook gesagt wir
die opfer und angehörigen vom
breitscheidplatz stehen hinter den
angehörigen und familien von hanau und
ich glaube mehr muss man dazu nicht
sagen
susanne wir haben rad gesehen dieser
notausgang der war versperrt das ist
eigentlich nicht in ordnung so aber die
staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei sind
dem nicht nachgegangen
ja definitiv nicht weil ich habe heute
auch sogar noch mal mit der
staatsanwaltschaft hanau gesprochen die
mir gesagt haben dass sie erst seit
november sozusagen ermitteln seit
november 2020 und zwar erst seit einer
der angehörigen in einem kann ich jetzt
hier nicht nennen anzeige erstattet hat
das heißt vorher nicht und wir wissen
eben weil uns der tatort bericht bekannt
ist vom 24
februar 2020 dass die polizei damals
festgehalten hat das eben die sprach von
türen verschlossen sind
dass das der notausgang war wissen wir
dass heißt danach ist ja nichts passiert
erst fast sieben minuten
sieben monate später ermittelt jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft und sie ermittelt
auch nur weil die angehörigen wieder
anzeige erstattet haben das heißt die
staatsanwaltschaft hat die polizei
berichtete nicht richtig gelesen oder
falsch gelesen die staatsanwaltschaft
sagt zu mir werte tatsächlich keine
chance gehabt davon zu erfahren wie
jetzt der fluss ist ich wunder mich
wirklich dass jedem essen tatort bericht
erstellt wird von der polizei die nicht
sofort reagiert und auch die
staatsanwaltschaft nichts davon
mitbekommt in die real ganz klar gesagt
wir haben jetzt erst im oktober anfang
november haben sie glaube ich die
anzeige erst bekommen im oktober hatte
hat diese person sie geschrieben
davon erfahren und danach haben wir die
ermittlungen also ab november
eingeleitet der täter von hanau ist ja
auch in einem umfeld groß geworden dass
ihn wahrscheinlich von kindheit oder von
jugend an radikalisiert hat der vater
fällt bis heute durch rechtsextreme
äußerungen und taten auf und auch hier
schauen wir mal kurz in seiner
dokumentation rein
nachdem der vater aus der
psychiatrischen behandlung damals
entlassung wurde bekam wierig die
überlebenden die angehörigen gefährden
ansprachen
wir sollen uns der vater doch ja nicht
nennen
ansonsten habe das schwere konsequenzen
für uns jetzt frage ich mich wer hier in
deutschland eigentlich welches warum
haben wir keine gefährdeten ansprache
bekommen seit april schreibt der vater
des täters an behörden erfordert die
waffen zurück er sieht seinen sohn als
opfer und für die wiedergutmachung sage
ich noch mehrere menschenleben
erforderlich wann will die polizei was
dagegen tun
der vater von tobias er hat in seinen
anzeigen aufgefordert die gedenkstätten
für die opfer vom 19 februar
abzuschaffen weil das volksverhetzung
sei hans-gerd er der vater des
terroristen kamen während der
demonstration aus seinem haus und
beschwerte sich darüber bei der polizei
danach erstattete er wieder anzeige
diesmal gegen teilnehmer der
demonstration
wörtlich heißt es die gruppe der wilden
fremden solle das maul halten und sich
dem deutschen volk und dem grundgesetz
vom 23 mai 1949 unterordnen
also dass auch eine weitere
merkwürdigkeit dass es diese
gefährderansprachen gegeben hat an die
hinterbliebenen die ja sagen eigentlich
hätte es umgekehrt sein sollen gab es da
von der polizei oder den behörden weil
irgendeine reaktion oder erklärung
darauf da hab ich gar nichts keine
antwort darauf bekommen also zu dieser
frage gar nicht was natürlich sehr sehr
verwunderlich ist überhaupt diese dann
ganze komplex mit dem vater von tobias
er dass die angehörigen wirklich den
eindruck hatten sie seien gefährlich und
nicht dieser vater weil die
staatsanwaltschaft hat jetzt auch keins
in keinster weise oder nur am anfang in
so als beschuldigten behandelt und dann
recht bald nur noch als zeugen und hat
nicht wirklich gegen ihn ermittelt
obwohl es eine zeugenaussage zum
beispiel vom vater gibt hat nämlich
gesagt er hätte von 20 bis 24 uhr
geschlafen
die zeugen die nachbarinnen eindeutig
widerlegen also nachbarin die ihn kennen
haben ihn tatsächlich gesehen
um 22.30 sagt eine zeugin habe sie ihn
draußen gesehen und eine sowie circa 23
30 was im prinzip total dem widerspricht
was der vater ausgesagt hatte bei der
polizei und dann fragt man sich
natürlich warum lügt er und die freude
die eine zeugin hatte auch berichtet der
komischerweise hinter dem haus zu dem
parkplatz des sohnes gegangen da stand
damals das auto von tobias er ja noch da
das war nach den morden aber vor der
stürmung des hauses und er hätte dann
mit einer taschenlampe irgendwas rein
geleuchtet und er hatte mir hagen kopf
und initiative 1900 februar gesagt sie
glauben dass er die waffe gesucht hat
von tobias er es ist ja ein fakt dass
die eine der waffen shadows die die
cello 2 im wagen verblieben war und erde
zu mir gesagt er möglicherweise was hat
er gesucht hat er die falsche gesuchte
ja da war wusste er was von den taten
ich meine da werden jetzt die ermittlung
des auch erst noch mal zeigen müssen
aber fakt ist sind wieder die an die
angehörigen die anzeige erstattet haben
jetzt vor kurzem erst ich glaube diese
woche
wegen beihilfe zum mord gegen den vater
von tobias r ich glaube der vater war
auch in der wohnung in der gemeinsame
und woher dann tobias r und die mutter
tot aufgefunden wurden gibt es
irgendeinen eine information darüber was
der vater zu diesem tag herr kahn gesagt
hat oder was da passiert sein soll
also es gibt keine informationen darüber
aber es stellt man stellt sich viele
fragen
aber die mutter ja dann erst später
erschossen wurde
da kann man natürlich fragen hat der
vater das mitbekommen der wenn er doch
im haus war muss er vielleicht was
mitbekommen haben
man kann ja auch fragen warum ist er
verschont geblieben aber dazu wissen wir
nichts das liegt alles bei der
bundesanwaltschaft glaube da müssen wir
den bericht erst mal abwarten
gibt es denn jetzt möglichkeiten diesen
menschen einzuschränken dass der der
versucht ja zum beispiel das gedenken
der opfer in der stadt zu verhindern da
möchte das denkmal was es dort gibt
möchte weg haben er stellt seinen sohn
als opfer dar und die hinterbliebenen
fühlen sich ja wohl von ihm auch bedroht
gibt es irgendwie möglichkeiten zu
verhindern dass es da zu einer neuen
eskalation und dass wir im neuen tat
kommt also wie gesagt jetzt wird erst
mal gegen ihn ermittelt aufgrund der
angehörigen wegen beihilfe zum mord die
staatsanwaltschaft selbst
ich glaub es hackt im beitrag auch
gehört hat die anklage erhoben gegen ihn
wegen beleidigung aber nicht wegen
volksverhetzung und eine wegen
beleidigung weil er ja da von den wilden
kerlen gesprochen hat mehr weiß ich in
diesem fall jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht
aber wir müssen das abwarten wenn jetzt
die angehörigen natürlich wegen beihilfe
zum mord ihn angezeigt haben dann werden
auch da jetzt natürlich die ermittlungen
in gang kommen hier gibt es jetzt fragen
bei uns im stream ob man den sind den
zitat rechtsradikalen schrott von seinem
vater senden muss susanne warum hast du
dich dazu entschieden das mit run zu
nehmen das zitat zum beispiel ja ja weil
ich meine es im prinzip klar macht ich
glaube das ist auch im sinne der
angehörigen was er genau so will und
verrückt ist und auch in dem fall
rassistisch wie sein sohn das ist ja das
was die angehörigen sagen der hat im
prinzip die gleich der neusser die
gleichen sachen er schreibt weder
anzeigen
er fällt auf er wohnt hier immer noch in
unserer nachbarschaft
die haben
sie halten ihn für gefährlich die sagen
der krise kann auch genauso explodieren
die sensoren hintergrund ist natürlich
auch dass sie denken vielleicht hat er
sogar mit ihm zusammengearbeitet das
weiß man natürlich nicht aber sie sagen
er ist gefährlich und wir möchten dass
er wenigstens unter kontrolle ist sie
gibt es jetzt auch ein kommentar der zum
beispiel den rassismus der ja dieser tat
zugrunde liegt herunterspielt das habe
ich oder haben wir nach der tat immer
wieder auch mitbekommen dass menschen
gesagt haben so wie jetzt zum beispiel
dieser kommentator klar dass die teils
schlimm aber nicht rassistisch spiel
quasi auf diese diagnostizierte
schizophrenie des täters an
was kannst du dazu sagen na ja verrückt
heißt ja nicht dass er nicht rassistisch
ist er ist auf eine auf der einen seite
natürlich verwirrt und der war ja auch
in der psychiatrie
das ist ja auch ein fakt aber er hat ja
trotzdem seine rassistischen und auch
meiner ansicht nach rechtsradikalen
botschaften im internet verbreitet das
ist ja das darf man ja damit nicht
entschuldigen das heißt das eine geht ja
mit dem anderen ja auch manchmal einher
der bundespräsident hat gerade in seiner
rede davon gesprochen dass es
unterstützung für die angehörigen von
der der opfer von hanno gegeben hat ich
weiß aber auch dass es eine petition
gibt für einen opferfonds der
angehörigen also die würdest du das
einschätzen gab es da genug
unterstützung auch finanzieller art für
die hinterbliebenen also der hessische
landtag hat jetzt vor kurzem einen
opferfonds beschlossen
den gab's ja vorher nicht für opfer von
straftaten
aber die angehörigen die hatten das ja
im prinzip auch gewollt die sind sehr
enttäuscht weil sie wollten eigentlich
einen opferfonds für opfer der
rassistischen rechtsradikalen gewalt und
natürlich für sie und das hat der
hessische landtag eben nicht geschafft
vier fraktionen haben ja ein kompromiss
sagen wir mal oder waren sich einig dass
man eben einen allgemeinen opfer von
geschätzt zwei millionen euro jährlich
und damit sind die angehörigen absolut
unzufrieden weil die haben ja wirklich
zum teil finanzielle nöte
die haben ja aufgrund dieses diese
dieser verluste ganz lange nicht
arbeiten können also einkommensverluste
dann haben ja viele gesagt wir konnten
ja gar nicht können da gar nicht mehr
weiterleben mit der vater von tobias er
lebt hier
die tatorte sind in kesselstadt direkt
in der nähe viele familien
in kassel staaten wollten eigentlich
auch viele wollten weg das heißt sie
müssen umziehen das kostet geld eine
neue wohnung zu mieten kostet immer geld
und es ist nicht so dass sie jetzt im
überfluss eine leben überhaupt nicht da
gibt es keine unterstützung von der
stadt oder vom land hessen doch doch die
haben ja wie gesagt jetzt ein aufruf
angeschlossen haben auch am anfang
familien haben geld bekommen aber das
hatten sie damals auch gebraucht jetzt
geht es darum wie gehen wir weiter mit
diesen menschen um und da gibt es jetzt
wie gesagt ein opfer von von zwei
millionen euro aber für die sagen wir
mal für die opfer aller straftaten und
damit sind sie unzufrieden
auch mit der höhe weil das reicht nicht
es sind ja viele opfer sind ja nicht nur
die angehörigen sind ja die überlebenden
die ja mit den folgen dieser tat kämpfen
und auch nicht arbeiten können das haben
ja ganz viele erzählt das heißt also zu
viel ist es sicherlich nicht
wie geht es jetzt weiter also es wird
ermittelt hast du schon gesagt der
bundesanwalt die bundesanwaltschaft
ermittelt weiter was ist der stand da
und wann können wir da quasi mit
ergebnissen rechnen also die
bundesanwaltschaft hat die ermittlungen
übernommen und die sagt ja die wird bald
die ermittlungsergebnisse vorstellen
bald heißt was das ist ja nicht aber
offensichtlich wird es bald erfolgen
denn es gab ja einen vorläufigen bericht
er wurde ja den familien geschickt damit
die anwälte mal drüber gehe gucken
können und ihnen noch was auffällt was
wir einnehmen wollen und der ist ja das
ist ja schon erfolgt das heißt jetzt
müssen sie es glaube ich bis ende des
monates im monat das mussten sie sich
äußern und irgendwann mal danach wann
das ist noch nicht ganz klar
wir warten weiter darauf dass armin
kutscha zu uns kommt und auch mit uns
spricht und vielleicht unsere fragen
beantworten kann die es ihm jetzt geht
nach dieser trauerfeier
ich würde die kollegen bitten dass wir
vielleicht bis dahin noch mal den
einspieler mit der chronologie dieser
nacht zeigen weil vielleicht einige
nicht so richtig mehr im hinterkopf
haben was dort eigentlich am 19 februar
in hanau passiert ist ich hoffe das
funktioniert jetzt
hanau 19 februar 20 20 gegen 22 uhr
nähert sich tobias er zwei lokalen am
heumarkt im zentrum von hanau in der bar
la botte erschießt einen mitarbeiter ko
an welt oft auf der straße vor der bar
fathi sarah schule in der shisha lounge
mit neid deren eigentümer sedat kürbis
tobias r wird draußen auf der straße von
willi viorel paarungen beobachtet dieser
sitz in seinem auto tobias r schießt auf
ihn aber willi verfolgt den täter
trotzdem zu seinem zweiten tatort
dort wird er später tot in seinem auto
aufgefunden
tobias erfährt nach hanau kesselstadt
dort schießt an einem kiosk und einer
benachbarten bar wieder um sich tötet
fünf menschen
gürkan gültekin mercedes kierpiec hansa
coach zeitmesser haschemi und verharrt
unwahr und verletzt weitere der täter
fährt weiter zu seiner wohnung ganz in
der nähe
dort erschießt er mutmaßlich seine
mutter dann sich selbst
insgesamt sterben bei dem rassistischen
anschlag elf menschen
und jetzt ist bei uns im stream habe ich
ein foto vich der vater von hamza coach
einem der opfer des attentäters von
hanau
schönen guten abend danke dass sie für
uns noch zeit gefunden haben oder abend
guten abend herr kurz so witzig wie geht
es ihnen jetzt nach dieser trauerfeier
hat ist ihnen irgendwie geholfen
nein ehrlich gesagt ich bin noch voller
emotionen aber ich musste ein paar
sachen aussprechen ich ausgesprochen
habe wie haben sie die worte des
bundespräsidenten erlebt er hat ja doch
auch für versöhnung plädiert er hat auch
fehler eingeräumt
wie war diese rede für die war sehr
aufrichtig um der herr bundespräsident
war seit dem anschlag hier
wir haben ja auch getroffen und der
kontakt ist auch nie abgebrochen
er hat auch angesprochen dass es hilfen
geben muss für die opfer für die
hinterbliebenen sind sie mit den hilfen
die sie bekommen haben unterstützung
zufrieden wir hatten doch wo diese
soforthilfe bekommen
das war's
das heißt die betreuung durch den
bundesrat beauftragt und durch den
landesbeauftragten
das heißt was würden sie sich wünschen
was fehlt ihnen
ehrlich gesagt ich persönlich würde mir
wünschen dass diese tat aufgearbeitet
wird
dass diese fehler eingestanden werden
und dass aus diesen fehlern lernen
gezogen werden dass ich so etwas nie
wieder wiederholen könnte sie erheben ja
auch große vorwürfe gegen die polizei
und gegen die behörden können sie
konkrete beispiele nennen die ihnen
besonders aufgestoßen sind und wo sie
kein verständnis für haben wie das
gelaufen ist also der notruf war in dem
in dieser tat nacht nicht erreichbar
das ist ja mittlerweile öffentlich der
umgang mit den toten
also mit unseren angehörigen wie die
dass man uns verweigert hat nötigen
abschied zu nehmen und dann ist noch die
sache mit dem notausgang dass dieser
notausgang verschlossen war dass man das
sei der tatnacht weiß und das erste
strafanzeigen gestellt werden müssen
dass die ihre amtspflicht nachkommen
das ist für sie nicht verständlich das
ist für mich nicht verständlich
wie sind denn die behörden mit ihm
umgegangen wenn sie dorthin gegangen
sind und gesagt haben was es hier mit
was ist was ist mit dieser mit dieser
tatsache haben sie das gefühl gehabt sie
werde ernst genommen
nein gucken sie mal die die schieben
immer den geraden bundesanwalt vor
das ist nicht aufgabe des genaue
bundesanwalt ist was den
generalbundesanwalt angeht wir hatten
ihnen ja einmal getroffen das
bundeskriminalamt und die waren auch
sehr bemüht und sie fragen zu
beantworten
zu laufenden ermittlungen können die
nicht antworten und das ist auch okay so
aber all diese sachen das ist
ländersache und dann wie ist der genaue
bundesanwalt nicht zuständig und das
land hessen hat ihnen nicht die
antworten interessant war gerne hätten
entschuldigung ich akustisch nicht
verstanden das land hessen hat ihnen
bislang nicht die antworten gegeben die
sie gerne hätten zb auf die frage warum
ihr sohn in den unterlagen als
orientalisch aussehend beschrieben
worden ist obwohl er ja eine blonde und
blauäugige junger mann gewesen
auf diese fragen warten wir auf die
antworten
aber es kann doch eigentlich nicht sein
dass sie diese frage stellen wir
überhaupt keine antwort bekommen das ist
ja fast nicht vorstellbar
es ist leider so
glauben sie denn dass er so noch am
leben gewesen leider ist es so glauben
sie denn dass er so noch am leben
gewesen wäre wenn dann notausgang in der
arena war an dem abend nicht
verschlossen gewesen wäre
also ich war da nicht drin in der
tatnacht die überlebenden sagen es alle
wir sind nicht dahin gelaufen weil wir
wussten dass abgeschlossen ist und
wissen sie oder schein das muss
überzeugt dass abgeschlossen war
ich weiß es nicht wenn man den leuten
zuhört didaktik nicht drin waren die
sagen dass die polizeibehörde es wusste
aber ein beleg dafür haben sie
wahrscheinlich nicht
nein leider nicht die polizei scheint ja
an diesem abend generell überfordert
gewesen zu sein und um nicht wirklich
gut vorbereitet auf so ein attentat
teilen sie diesen eindruck
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich kein mensch ist
auf so etwas vorbereitet
niemand und wir als familien am
allerwenigsten
so viele tote an zwei orten darauf kann
man sich vorbereitet sind
aber es geht ja durchaus dinge dass man
zum beispiel nicht jemanden der
angeschossen ist erstmal nach seinem
ausweis fragt sondern genau weiß dass
man ihnen sofort verarzten muss das
berichtet hier einer der überlebenden
das eben er war angeschossen am hals und
an der schulter und das erste was ein
polizist macht ist nach dem ausweis zu
fragen das sind doch routinen die
sollten das eigentlich so nicht geben
oder
da sind wir uns einig sowas darf nicht
sein
nichts geht über ein menschenleben der
bundespräsident hat in seiner rede auch
gesagt lassen sie uns glauben an die
kraft des miteinanders haben sich diesen
glauben noch härter wird ja
ich muss daran glauben und ich glaube
immer noch an diesen rechtsstaat
obwohl sie das gefühl haben dass er sie
hängen lässt
vorerst schon aber im endeffekt dürfen
sich spalten lassen
das würde ich so stehen lassen hergovich
ich danke ihnen dass sie nach dieser
trauerfeier noch zeit für uns gefunden
haben und wünsche ihnen viel kraft für
die nächsten tage und wochen
ich danke danke und damit danke ich
jetzt auch euch und ihnen fürs zu sehen
dieses nicht einfach ein thema
ich danke allen die in den kommentaren
sich mitfühlend geäußert haben die
solidarität gezeigt haben und auch uns
ein paar fragen gestellt haben
ich würde sagen das ist das ende einer
aufregenden woche ein schwieriges ein
trauriges ende
aber wir wissen es geht weiter und wie
herkunft wird sagte wir dürfen uns nicht
spalten lassen das würde ich jetzt
einfach mal mit uns ins wochenende gehen
von daher macht es gut und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]